it's amusing after your morning coffee
or tea to start tapping on the Kapadia
spoon it's pretty much the same pitch
everywhere
thankthank time whatever it is and then
maybe it's the characteristic pitch of
this cup and if you take another cup
another spoon for that matter maybe you
get the different sound who knows so
maybe it's always the same pitch from
this particular cup if tapped by the
spoon but then I started tapping
somewhere else those four points emit
the common pitch and those four points
also emit a common bit but a higher
pitch than those four points we'll
explore what's causing this but you
might first think that he has to do with
a handle that seems to be a very
suspicious culprit and thank you very
much for pointing that out oh of course
he has to the handle but if it has to
the handle wouldn't you have thought
that this half closer the handle and
this half further from the handle should
behave differently but that's not how
the Symmetry's broke indeed in point
next to the handle and point farthest
from the handle behaves exactly the same
way where as 45 degrees off you get the
higher pitch it has to do a handle
perhaps but the symmetry breaking
pattern is not so naive as we at the
first thought let's understand what's
happening and in order to do this we'll
break it up in two stages first we'll
understand why any quadruplet of four
points that form the vertices of square
always give you the same pitch common
[ __ ] and then we understand why this
quadruplet emits a higher pitch than
those four points okay so let's forget
about the handle so the handle pretend
the handle is not there when we cut this
point we are making this point vibrate
we are setting it in motion like this
well roughly speak
in the point diametrically opposite can
react in one of the two ways when this
point is doing that the other point can
go like this or go like this we say in
phase or out of phase now this reaction
this response is essentially moving the
cap back and forth back and forth
studying it as a total rigid body as a
whole body and it does not really target
the approximation deform data but of
course the sound has to do with the
deformation look up how it's vibrating
altogether and so on so this is not
producing sound that's not what you're
hearing what you're hearing is this
response when this point moves back and
forth this goes in and out at the same
time like this
professor what does that make a sound by
the way because sound means that
somebody for example it can be your
throat it can be for example birds
chirping you can be up chiming is
vibrating very very fast and shaking air
around it and when you shake the air
like this the air next to it gets
compressed and bounces off because air
has some elasticity and then that bounce
compresses next part there are masses of
and there is a wave that propagates like
this towards the camera and eventually
reaches the ear and inside the eardrum
this wave is shaking the atom and that's
what you hear as a sound okay so the
vibration and the deformation ultimately
of the very rapid to deformation of the
cup is producing the sound and this
response is not really deforming as this
one is so and this is what is primarily
responsible for the sound on the other
hand the cup as a whole doesn't want to
change its volume if you can help it
wants to stay as incompressible as
possible in other words when those two
go in well by reaction these two are
pushed out in order to keep the same
volume and if these go out these two put
in so that you get this kind of rhombus
type oscillation boom poom poom poom
poom poom-poom
and that's why any quadruple to four
points that form the vertices of square
are always singing unison it doesn't
matter which of the four points use that
exciting all the other three follow and
four together go into this loss and
rhombus vibration well so we now
understand why this quadruple points and
this quadrant points each and emits a
common pitch now why this quadruple
duple points a higher pitch than this
quadruplet points a lower pitch in order
to understand that we must resurrect a
handle that we have been neglecting so
far so the handle comes back you see
when let's say that we excite one of the
four points those those four points as
we saw it doesn't matter which of the
four points you excite because all of
them work in unison but one of those
four points are vibrating together they
have to take the hand or drag the handle
with them because you see one of the
points vibrating point is attached to
the handle so the handle must move back
and forth while those four points
vibrating in contrast when those four
points are made to vibrate you remember
what happens when this goes in this goes
at and this goes in is goes out the
point just in between is what we call an
OD in other words to a good
approximation it's stationary it doesn't
move in between so as far as this
quadruple points are concerned the
handle is invisible it's as if the
handle were not there because it's
attached the point that's not doing any
vibration revolution of motion so we now
have two elastic systems you can think
of them as Springs if you like this one
and this one one of them is attached to
some heavy mass that it has to drag
along the other one it's not attached to
anything because this is invisible to
those four points and they are made of
the same state material that is the cup
so imagine two Springs one of them is
attached the heavy mass and the other
one is not attached the heavy mass and
when you let them go what you hear the
heavy one goes whoa
in a very sluggish way where is the
rectangles here on eHow and that's the
difference of the pitch that we hear and
that is why these four points with a low
pitch whereas those four points in the
higher pitch so far we saw it handle us
and we try to figure out what this sound
pattern was like the inverse problem is
also interesting by which I mean since
we are talking about the pitch of the
sound that we hear let's imagine
ourselves in a pitch dark room say that
we walk into this room we don't know
where the handle is
but imagine that we are allowed to go
around the cup tapping it everywhere and
record the sound pattern that we get
from each point from that recorded data
of the sound pattern can we reconstruct
where the handle was that is the inverse
problem a bit more abstractly speaking
instead of saying that we know the cause
and then by solving whatever
mathematical model partial differential
equations but whatnot you try to predict
what the effect is going to be we are
going the other direction we have this
observed data effects if you like which
we know to be true anyway we just see
this and we try to figure out what on
earth is causing is responsible for the
production of this effect so this is the
inverse problem rather than for the
problem and if you think about it much
of the scientific endeavor is really
about solving an inverse problem we want
to get to the bottom of things we want
to recover the cause and this very very
simple everyday morning breakfast
example shows that the inverse problem
is not always naively solvable indeed
you probably agree with me that if I
took a cup and rotated by 90 degrees the
basic pattern that we hear in a
north-south east-west and so on and in
between will be the same we don't know
where the handle is up to 90 degree
rotation you know it can be here here
here here so we can narrow it down to
four possible positions yes
well okay so there is some sort of
ambiguity and
as regards the position because the
handle can be here here or here or here
and you will get the same pattern of the
noise but there is something even worse
you can't even tell the number of
handles because instead of having a
Dodge handle here you could have to make
me medium handles and you agree that the
pattern of the vibration will be the
same Oh indeed for small handles here
and here here and you'd probably get
still the same but we call the ground
state or the same kind of vibration
pattern so you can't even tell the
number of handles and you can tell the
position of handles but up the symmetry
you can actually start saying something
and this is a very typical solution a
typical situation you want to mode out
you have you have to sort of neglect and
somehow take out the symmetry and then
start solving the problem anyway so this
very simple example shows that the
inverse problem is honorable not always
suitable but you can actually say
something when you sort of start
handling the symmetry in a clever way if
we turn the lights out and I was trying
to figure out the cup yet I do it we in
general can't but we can say something
up to symmetry you know we know that for
example there aren't three handles
because that would break and symmetry in
a completely different manner in fact
ever since I noticed this phenomenon
I've been looking for a cup with three
handles because that would be very
interesting and recently a friend of
mine Brian White of Stanford got me two
cups and one of them has three handle ah
now I'm unfortunately it's not a very
nice cup in there in any it is a big
very beautiful cup but for our purposes
for our purposes it's not very well
performing cup because it doesn't really
turn a stick and in between so it's
somewhat interesting I mean those three
points and those three points in between
emit a common pitch but in between I'm
not sure that I can do this except you
can't really hear the difference
it's a very very small difference yeah
so in between there's a slight rising of
the pitch that I'd like to hear more
clearly so we need a larger cup by the
way and this is a very chubby chunky mug
from Stanford math department but if you
take a really well made thin and
delicate china cup I know this charm is
so much more beautiful so I recommend it
arrows three
well it's 3 to the 3 to the threat you
ain't seen nothing yet
ok so here we go 3 4 if one more error
well what does this mean
3 3 arrows of 3 3 arrows